okay so this is five short grapples hell
is a great story is that really what it
is what the term means Oh actually I'm
guessing like a fable yeah okay if
you're gonna talk come here she's layin
over there holding a little bunny rabbit
yeah no I think she's right don't wanna
feel like a little story is how I always
took it yeah I don't know if it's a real
word or not but so this starts off with
evil Phillips who I love I love the emo
Philips starts at all kind of tried to
disguise his voice which I like because
that's like the hardest voice to hide
and he doesn't okay job actually and
when he starts off saying that we're
going to show you five stories and they
all have a similar theme can you guess
what the theme is while you're watching
it and Jason was saying in there too is
even you really guess what it is and all
of us were watching this and I'm trying
to keep focus I want what's the
connection on the ball and it's it's
these five a little short that me it's
only 11 minutes oh they can't be I mean
they really are a short yeah it's like
five the wands and and we do finally get
clarification that Bebo is a boy because
said I'm at the bike so that definitely
you know now we know I still go same for
people to sit there and go well actually
this is unless there's some sort of what
is that come o drugs this is drugs drugs
Jesse no you can't take drugs so they go
and they do this great big us five
stories here and if any Jake want do the
ultimate high five and bubblegum is
making the ultimate sandwich lumpy Space
Princess wants to do a talent show that
somebody else does and the Ice King
realizes he stings sing these out loud
now it's like dammit I could I not get
this
you know Phyllis is at the MA says you
know oh did you get it wasn't that
incredibly easy
oh you haven't gotten it well I'll give
you a point in the video to pause so you
can think about it and they let me give
you a moment which is very clever and
that's actually what he did he paused
and asked us all key guess what it is
and the only thing I could say oh now
I'm forgetting what it was that I said
was everyone was trying to impress
someone else it was all about impressing
something that's the only thing I could
think of and it was the census it was
all five senses everyone had to do with
a different one of the senses and that
was pretty clever it's totally pointless
I mean you could take this out and I
don't think we would ever gain or lose
anything with the exception of finding
out that BMO's male yeah that's that's
about it but I kind of like these little
stories you know reminds me of that was
the like 22 short tales about
Springfield or whatever you know just
sort of these I like stories word
sometimes you could just see the
characters breathe' be themselves it
doesn't have to be this big event that
their own has to rush around uh which
every time does that well even within
the big event you sort of see characters
in their natural habitat which I like
you see them just relaxing or chilling
and it's it's a very welcoming
environment that they made you know
until the monsters come I had to fight
them off but even that looks like a lot
of fun when they do it you want to go to
the land if you really go actually you
want to hang with these people it's like
it's fun having these adventures but
it's also fun just hanging with them
yeah so so this is one that's mostly
centered around just people just having
fun and goofing around just seeing them
be themselves you know it was fun I like
the challenge of trying to find what the
connection is to it and I like the fact
I couldn't get it I thought that was
weird
- more - later on Oh two more it doesn't
that guy - the evil Phil yeah the emo
Philips does return for both of them
okay and is in now they were trying to
find what they don't actually okay no
that sounds like fun there
on the road and it's like well I'm saw
the second one this is awesome so yeah
bad now it now it's like I'm gonna look
like even harder this time I'll get even
more pissed off when I get um but uh ya
know I thought it was I thought I've
looked forward to two more I'm just good
I think that'd be great fun how about
you um I definitely liked what they did
and what oh yeah I like what the
Princess Bubblegum the little in my
opinion the short tiny little reference
to the fly the David Cronenberg fly with
the the squid and the balloon is the
machine she puts him in oh that's our
exact same and she gets the button which
transports it and combines them to the
other one which is the fly yeah the part
I really liked in there was when she
puts the cow in the machine which is
which is now male you know and she just
puts in there and she just gives a
little kiss he just goes and then just
it's like looking up an estimate she
starts going it just goes I'm just like
oh my god just that little all man is
gonna be so great to say you're gonna
hear his rookie act as it goes faster
and faster and that really cracked me
also really laughing art I also liked
what the eye skin is so dark what he did
at the same time it's like the penguin
swims back it's like yeah later after
the bath he walks up just goes like did
they just fall asleep or passed out that
was sorry that was I thought that was
even darker Wow um the other thing that
um I'm probably not that's my guess but
it reminds me a lot of the one where he
goes oh have you figured out let me give
you a second I mean you probably trace
that to some kids show maybe but what it
reminds me of is there's a movie
hold the beasts must die okay it's this
movie its amicus UK movies going on and
people are being killed by a werewolf
and so the movie coming to the end and
it's like this murder mystery if you
will and it stops and it says have you
figured out who the werewolf is and
there's called the werewolf break
there's those pictures of each of the
characters that are left with a little
timer going and then it stops and goes
in and then that finally reveals who the
killer was
and I'm like that much time do they give
uh it's like a thirty seconds okay like
it's a thirty second thing and like that
was the first time I ever saw that and
this movies I think from the 70s wow I'm
like that's just great so when I saw
them to do it here to me at least that's
the first thing that popped in my head
and it makes me think because of the
connection to the fly it's like okay did
someone who's into horror movies right
this one I don't know there is a lad to
be a little bit of a comedy though to
write the beasts must die no actually
it's not scary and they actually still
do that I would say straight well it's a
murder mystery with the little bit of
milk a tiny bit of gore and then that
pops up and you're kind of like thrown
off you're like wait what the hell am i
watching now but yeah I wouldn't it's
definitely not a comedy but yeah that's
definitely odd okay that way you know I
think as they like how they movies
actually do that where they allow you to
sort of pause the movie or pause the
show or whatever it's not that I mean
it's like we always kind of like make
jokes about in our videos and stuff like
that I think you probably see more
online like yeah yeah no no no pause
that look it up you know blah blah blah
like we make more jokes about but yeah
actual like movies and TV shows yeah you
don't see that bad on yeah it's funny
oh and it's it's actually very polite to
give you a pause here what I'm just
imagining that I've been the movie first
came out in the theaters people sitting
there yelling at the screen who knows
I imagine like a fight breaking out over
it MPA don't be honest I would be an
awesome awesome oh yeah
doesn't you have to be a good movie for
that point it's just like it's just a
seal right over who the world these
people are invested but ya know I
thought was funny it was sort of you
know in kind of pointless but sometimes
it's fun BMO is cute it actually wasn't
a he'd peed and then it pans over to
Finn and Jake going so they watched be
mopey but he did pee sitting down
that's true even though it's just
pouring but that make even more sense to
do it standing up so I I still can't see
b-boys May it's such a distinctly female
voice especially knowing that it's
rainbow core it's I can't a lot of times
it's like even if you know a woman's
doing like a boy's voice it's like okay
no I can buy it and say you know I'm
Bart Simpson I know it's a woman but I
hear oh boy you're a Bart Simpson but
it's like I just always hear a Korean
woman doing that I didn't never not hear
that well did this mean person clear
that Bart is a male everything about
Bart is male yeah the problem with BMO
is BMO's of video game system yes he
says he's a boy I'm a boy yeah but then
again is he pretending he's also talking
to himself in acting like he's brushing
his teeth and acting like he's open I
mean so couldn't he be playing a part
um I guess maybe it's one of those
things where it's like just because he
has no real identity reaches program to
have a consciousness it's a kind of like
a uni sex thing yeah I guess that's my
guess so could be I don't know so why
would he say he's a boy but pee sitting
down very strange yeah soon we think
about in these people looks this is the
deep thought that we challenge you with
and I got nothing else
that's okay closing thoughts yeah this
is pig bunny big rabbit
her name's mean you go mean you shut